should we talk about it what happened
the tragedy uh mr virgil
is is gone he is no longer with us um
virgil abloh you guys probably know from
uh creating off-white yeah he's also had
other brands he created head of louis
vuitton now creative director yeah of
men's for louis vuitton and then i think
the first one he created was that maybe
we were all familiar with was a brand
called pyrex
and um
and he died of cancer nobody knew he had
cancer
and uh which is becoming increasingly
popular amongst uh i guess famous people
this idea of like not milking that
trauma or not even sharing that trauma
yeah uh take note tick-tock
don't make me sick take note
you don't need to share what happened to
you in your [ __ ] day about how
difficult it was and put that stupid
song in the background you don't need to
do that it's okay something shitty can
happen to you and you can keep it to
yourself you don't immediately have to
share it on [ __ ] tiktok or instagram
or whatever um
so virgil ends up passing away uh tragic
and um
he represented something that was really
interesting he represented like in the
in the fashion industry
uh talent not clout
now when you have talent there's clout
associated with it yeah but
he would create things i think the
easiest thing to make something cool in
fashion is to take what is the least
cool thing and attach a person of
stature to it um either a model or
someone that's like uh an influencer
within the fashion world and then all of
a sudden becomes cool connie and kim
started wearing champion and then
champion hoodies became the [ __ ]
perfect example another example is like
the dad nikes yeah remember so it's like
what's the least cool sneaker ever okay
a dad nike throw it on now it's cool
because it's not cool right and then
eventually enough people that are cool
wear it and it becomes cool again yeah
grandma sweaters kind of had like a
little moment 100 basically anything
kanye does is that right and to me it's
the easiest version of fashion so uh so
basically uh what i liked about virgil
was is that he created cool [ __ ] he took
cool things and made them cooler right
he could go and get like the worst
[ __ ] sneaker and go okay i'm gonna
try to like add some sauce to this and
make it cool but he'll take a [ __ ]
air force one a sneaker that we wear
that we already like and make the
coolest version of that the jordan one
the chicago the most
and cool and make it even cooler even
better yeah like he the guy had real
[ __ ] true creative talent it wasn't
just let me throw a famous person on
this a richard mealwatch that's like all
right if i can get obj to wear it during
the game i guess it's really cool now
these rappers pay a million dollars for
the watch so i guess it's cool there's
nothing good about it richard milwaukee
i don't i'm not impressed by it i'm not
impressed by objectively ugly to look at
yeah maybe the inner workings of it if
you're a real watch nerd you know how i
don't even think that mad gaudy not into
it i don't know they're going to have
their run and they're all going to say
that that's why i don't have a richard
miller it's like a super guy
but he actually was a true creative it
wasn't clout it was creativity and then
when you're a true creative and then
it's executed and people love it of
course there's cloud associated with it
but it was he was a true [ __ ]
creative how often do you get that in
this you know marketplace where you can
get things that are absolutely worthless
and give them value if another people
believe in it yeah like we live in the
crypto times where like if we just
believe in three letters enough people
can come [ __ ] millionaires off of it
and i'm not saying it's necessarily bad
i hope that we all become [ __ ]
millionaires off of it but it's really
cool to see someone create a thing or
improve upon a thing that we already
think is great with just cool ideas and
great aesthetic and that is why uh yeah
he'll be missed yeah it was sad for me
because i think he was already great but
like where he was gonna go i think it
was gonna be like i thought he was gonna
be like a name in the way like louis
vuitton is a name that just lives on and
it was just sad to see somebody that's
it's like if michael jordan walked away
after like his second maybe third
championship and then never
yeah definitely if he never came back
yeah once he came back you're like oh my
god this is the a whole new level of
greatness yeah i think that's kind of
what it feels like when it got cut short
now all y'all [ __ ] who were
canceling him for not paying 50
for the black lives matter y'all feel
bad now you know what's impressive that
he didn't tell people he had cancer
right there i would have said it i would
have said it so
fast cooked for the pop smoke my black
life matters yeah i'm donating to chemo
to save my black life
that's what i would have said to all the
[ __ ] 100 and he still came out
i was like yo i did i i donated 25k to
you know bail or whatever like that to
people who got arrested at the marches
like he still felt the need to say it
but like yo real talk the guy's going
through [ __ ] chemo he knows he has
cancer cancer's probably going to kill
him people are [ __ ] on him for a 50
donation it's like
aggressive cancer he knows he's dying
soon yeah and he's just letting y'all
take your stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you're
so out of touch you know what you out of
touch with [ __ ] cancer people
were saying with the pop smoke i've been
covered like man it seems like really
phoned it in like he wasn't really
trying i'm like yeah he's doing it from
a hospital bed probably yeah
what was what was the album cover yeah
oh i remember that [ __ ] yeah they were
[ __ ] on it yeah
i was thinking about why celebrities
aren't announcing and i thought about
this if you announce you have a terminal
illness you get eulogized early on you
get a lot of love but if you keep living
people are going to start to be like hey
[ __ ] why are you still here oh
wow i think that's why you're like i
don't want to deal with that you know
that's interesting i saw you're mad
intrusive already but on top of that if
i live you're going to be upset if i
beat it y'all gonna be like